these hollywood stars not only had to
share their first smooch with a
co-worker
and in front of a production crew but
all the world got to see it
unfold on screen here's a look at some
movie scenes that captured an actor's
first
kiss dakota fanning might not have been
the top build member of the cast for the
2002 rom-com sweet home alabama
but the film probably ranks among the
most personally significant
parts of her filmography because it just
so happened to feature her first
real-life kiss fanning who was still
working her way to childhood stardom at
the time appeared in the film's opening
scene alongside another young actor
named thomas curtis
the two played the younger versions of
the central southern sweethearts reese
witherspoon's melanie smooter
and josh lucas's jake perry prancing
around the beach during a thunderstorm
jake pesters young melanie to marry him
she declines
saying she has a lot of life to lead but
she does cave to a kiss
however their smooch is quickly
interrupted by mother nature making a
rare second lightning strike in the same
spot
fanning would later call the scene quote
hot stuff for a 7 and a 10 year old
even so she also admitted that she quote
wasn't really into it
and would wipe her mouth off between
takes considering she was so young
and it was so forced fanning doesn't
actually count the moment as her
real first kiss and insists the real
deal came along several years later
under very different circumstances there
are probably millions of women who wish
they could say their first kiss was
shared with brad pitt
especially in his prime sexiest man
alive winning days
for kirsten dunst that was indeed a
reality on the set of the 1994 thriller
interview with the vampire
unfortunately for her she was just 11
years old at the time
while he was already 30 so it was hardly
a romantic experience for either
actor she later remembered on conan
although i thought it was
disgusting it was like i was 11 it would
have been weird if i was like this is
amazing i'm chasing brad pitt
mercifully dunst added that there was
quote no tongue involved and it was pc
enough so that the screen kiss didn't
intimidate the next fella to plant one
on her
off screen a fellow 8th grader on a
field trip
josh hutcherson is likely better known
for his on-screen kisses with jennifer
lawrence in the hunger games films
but long before he ever made way to the
capitol arena the then
child actor shared his first kiss in a
scene for the 2005 romantic film little
manhattan
opposite charlotte ray rosenberg
hutcherson starred as a kid named gabe
who goes in for a kiss on the girl he
likes
and then proceeds to torture himself
with a very relatable
inner monologue did i do it right
i don't know i have absolutely nothing
to compare it to
my god was i even close as conflicted as
his character was
hutcherson has admitted to having been
even more distressed by the experience
of having an
audience for the shot he told 17
magazine that not
one but both of his parents were on set
for the scene to help calm his nerves in
addition to the stacked production crew
he said it was a horrible first kiss
because i had a crew of like 50 people
standing around watching me
it was the most non-real non-intimate
moment that i could possibly have for my
first kiss i think
cersei ronan might be an accomplished
actress now but long before she would
become a household
name she made her feature film debut in
the little scene 2007 amy heckerling
dramedy i could never be your woman
not only did it mark her first silver
screen role it also featured her first
kiss opposite michelle pfeiffer the then
pre-teen start as a kid full of the
usual social fears and anxieties and
is unsure if the boy she likes shares
her interest lo and behold the boy
played by rory kopis does apparently
share her crush
and the two decide to lean in for a kiss
after bonding over video games
ronan later told w magazine that she had
to do 8
takes of the scene and felt that she
really quote suffered for her art
because she spent the whole time
counting out the requisite 3 seconds her
smooches were supposed to last in her
head
she explained i was a proper prude as
well i was not ready to kiss a boy
myself
though i was a phenomenal kisser by the
end
in the 2002 dramedy roger dodger jesse
eisenberg made his movie debut as a teen
whose uncle decides to take him out on
the town to meet women
they eventually link up with two women
and one of them played by jennifer beals
decides to give eisenberg's character a
kiss
unlike others on this list it's hardly
some small peck and it certainly didn't
seem to leave a bad taste for the actor
don't spoil the wonderful time we had
tonight eisenberg told wnyc
i was 18 or 19 years old it was the
first movie i got to be in
and i got to kiss her that was before i
even had a girlfriend or a date so it
was a great experience
i don't know if she agrees but for me it
was life-changing
based on what biels would later say of
the experience she wasn't quite as
personally affected by the scene but at
least he can re-watch the film
anytime he likes if he wants to
reminisce
when it comes to kids kissing on screen
it doesn't get much
more authentic than 1991's my girl the
now classic tearjerker featured anna
chlumsky and mccully culkin
who were each barely into double digit
age when they filmed the scene
sharing a smooch just to find out what
all the fuss is about like their
characters they were each novices to the
practice and didn't seem to be overly
impressed with the kissing after it was
done
chlumsky was even quoted as saying yuck
in between takes
the pair went on to win the 1992 mtv
movie award for best kiss
with chlumsky accepting solo and
quipping gee my first kiss and i get an
award
it may not have been impactful enough to
keep the actors in touch later on in
life but it did give generations of
other kids a pro tip
on what to do if a first kiss doesn't
quite live up to the hype
stand up and start reciting the pledge
of allegiance because it sure beats
saying the wrong thing in such a
situation
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one